unlike the previous Star Trek continuous
episodes this one takes place
exclusively in the mirror universe which
is a fan favorite it picks up where Mir
Mir left off and shows what happened
when Prime Kirk left and Mir Kirk came
back going to the mirror universe and
revisiting it and continuing literally
shot-for-shot this episode for me is one
of my personal favorites and it's a it's
a fan favorite so mind-blowing what
they're doing with the story and the
characters and the development the idea
of an alternate reality was not really
made popular in science fiction and told
this episode happened people have no
idea how iconic that episode is and how
much it influenced science fiction and
popular culture over the last 50 years
even little things like a guy with a
goatee is the evil version of yourself
that was established by Jerome Bixby in
the original Mir mirror episode for this
episode in particular transitioning into
having goatee and a mustache is is
tricky it's several hundred dollars to
to find it and it's it's custom cut it's
hand woven and so it's very much like
everything that is involved in this
production there's a lot of attention to
detail we didn't want to like this just
like any original series episode we
wanted to light it like Mirror Mirror
Mirror Mirror the episode was was lit
differently than a lot of the other
episodes it was lit darker it was lit
with slashes of light you got the barn
door it's pretty closed off yeah it's
just a stripe down you guys and a lot of
these scenes we're shooting in the same
sets the same areas that characters were
in in Mirror Mirror we needed to match
that so we screen capped near mirror and
we we put it on our phones and we look
through it and as we're shooting we're
referencing the original episode she was
lesson frame on our tape and she is here
making sure that everything is exactly
how it was and exactly lit how it was in
the original episode hadn't turned more
toward me and pushing open
yet more here it's tricky I've kind of
started playing Spock making them my own
but then when you revisit something like
this you kind of have to also keep in
mind how boy did it really but - but
it's a total change of how Spock is
because now is that there's an edge
there's a coldness in it and it almost
an evil to it for Star Trek fans that's
the part that's interesting about this
sort of part of the genre part of the
Mara Mara episode is that you get to see
these characters you know and love
behaving in ways that you would never
see them behaving well the mirror Scotty
differs in a way where he's he's just a
little bit more gruff a little bit more
mean in the merry universe yeoman Smith
is now a lieutenant so it's an
interesting transition from this eager
wanting to please lieutenant Smith to
being verbally abused by Kirk and not
being able to please him it's a fun
transition mirror universe McCoy it's
kind of Mengele it's kind of twisted and
sadistic which is fun because he's not
McCoy isn't at all so it's fun to just
sort of let that out let that be part of
his character Kirk prime before he
leaves really put Spock on the spot and
says hey you know this is coming are you
just gonna sit by and let it happen are
you gonna take action it is a very
kinetic episode where Spock is the
aggressor really one of the reasons that
people respond to the MIR universe so
much is because there is a fear that our
world is closer to that and could become
closer to that then we would like to
admit even people who haven't seen much
of the original series have seen this
episode it was an episode that ended
leaving the audience wondering what
happened next in the mirror universe
it's a story that every kid who grew up
watching Star Trek pictured in their
heads and the wonderful thing about this
is that we're telling that story
want to see more Star Trek continues
subscribe to the wired Channel